people didn't want to sell you drugs
because you were too scary look like you
were yeah that's how i got the name
booger from the revenge of the nerds but
when you live and play the undercover
role you're playing the bad guy you know
especially when you're living it i mean
i'd spend hours or days you know all i
mean a year with and you know you kind
of get that mentality like that [ __ ] i
gotta remember on the police
[Music]
look man i appreciate y'all being here
today um you know look i think we're
we're out of time i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna try to you know you know
pontificate on this but we're at a i
think uh incredibly complicated time
right now for law enforcement in this
country and it's a big reason why i
think i stepped forward to to try to um
even do this you know after what
happened with with george floyd and like
the entire
nation was sort of like focused on this
you know i found myself my cousin had
just died from kobe that was up in the
you know where in my home where i live
you know in the country
and you know i saw all these people sort
of marching in this movement against you
know what those
officers did that day and and you know
to be honest with you you know that like
that really resonated with me like i
thought like what that guy did was was
really wrong but then i put on the tv
and i saw people um you know throwing
bottles at police officers and throwing
things at police officers and that like
killed me because i know every single
one of those people is a father a
husband a brother uh you know a son you
know a sister and uh
you know i just
felt that you know in that moment right
there
you know why can't i be both why can't i
say what that guy was wrong but also be
extraordinarily pro-law enforcement
understand the necessity of police
officer understand the the pressure that
the police are under and uh understand
you know how unbelievably misguided it
would be
to let the actions of a few um take down
this institution that where i think
people are taking you know perhaps the
most uh important walk by putting on a
uniform every single day and going out
and keeping us safe
i'll stop talking in a second but i've
been enormously blessed i think in in my
career for for a whole host of reasons i
get you know i do what i love and i get
paid for and all that [ __ ] but you
know the best thing without a doubt you
know about what i do is is going into
these different places you know meeting
the folks that um
you know my character meeting the folks
that that live in the world that these
characters would would play and getting
to train with them get to know them and
i've developed literally you know
lifelong life-changing friends and um
you know man you and me
uh now i love you with every bit of my
heart man you know like we've known each
other for [ __ ] a decade now and um
you know and you introduced me to tony
i've wrote out with you
everybody in your unit you know every
all those guys i just immediately had
love for and had an immense amount of
respect for and then most recently i got
to work with uh with with dre
you know in baltimore and um you know we
we got to hit it really hard you know um
we got to get on those streets in in a
really really major way in in a big city
that i think is also sort of at the
forefront of um
you know uh uh a city really being taken
over by by violence a city really
suffering from the the scourge of
handcuffing your police department not
letting them police the way they want to
police and um you know dre and i have
known each other now you know for a
little little less than a year but it's
it's another one of those we're going to
be brothers in front yeah i love this
man we got to be you know forever so you
know let's just start you know carl how
how long was your career in law
enforcement uh 32 years and the majority
of it was working narcotics
just about the whole career was working
undercover narcotics when i was when i
met you i was lieutenant over the unit
10 years ago and i'll never forget the
first time i met you i mean i didn't
have any clue who the hell you were
when i first met john in fact we were in
the car riding and we were going up
through the hood and stuff like that and
i was showing you filming locations for
snitch
and uh you and rick
and uh i met john he was in the back
seat and i looked back and said so what
do you do he goes i'm an actor but you
probably never seen any kind of [ __ ]
i was like oh okay so anyway we just hit
it off right after that and i actually
introduced john to uh you were wanting
to know about playing drug dealers and i
introduced you to one of the old og guys
you remember
oh [ __ ] you're that that's uh that
informant yeah at the [ __ ] uh in the
parking lot in the parking lot
that's right man yeah he was taking the
pistol when we walked in in the middle
of the door i was like that ain't
[ __ ] we're like we gotta go meet my
talk to me i said you give him money
he'll tell you whatever the hell you
want to know
and oh yeah yeah that's the first time
john and i and that was it we just hit
it off since then and and and tony like
he's kind of a legend around he's part
like how how would you describe him
oh
i mean he's
he's a good
he was my supervisor in narcotics uh he
pretty much taught me everything that i
knew that i know now
uh
man it's just i don't know a lot of
words can describe you know what he
means to everybody he introduced me my
wife
uh
you know
i don't i don't even have words i could
describe you know the love that we have
for him and a lot of it also is just
like beyond i think like like like with
dre like a lot of the folks that you
introduced me to i think there's
something about like the plainclothes
kind of like aggressive tactic policing
uh in this country where it's units and
it seems to me that there's like an
unbelievable amount of closeness that
are that that's kind of um bred and
fostered in those units and that's
because you guys um your job is just
much more unsafe than
we're with each other more than we're
with our own family so
i mean 24 hours ago yeah i mean yeah i
mean i spent more time with him and the
time that he was my supervisor than i
did with find my own kids so you know
then you're in life and death situation
together and
you know it just
makes you a lot closer so and i know
with you and in baltimore with like the
gun tray stuff and and the plain clothes
you didn't really do undercover it's
just plain clothes yeah i wanted to i
wanted to do it on the cover but that's
a completely different animal i never i
never did on the cover you see workers
it doesn't seem like there is much you
see it working it's a little different
baltimore um
because it's so dangerous you know what
do you see work i don't know if you guys
carried
while you were
oh [ __ ] yeah oh did you carry it
dude these [ __ ] care about this
that's crazy like i'm carrying right now
you see detectives don't carry
what right because oh my god i mean like
the element of the uh
the criminals in baltimore they're so
street smart like you
there was an instance that you know
there was there was a gun and it was
probably it was used against they were
going to use it against the detective so
they figured
it's better not to carry
but it's very you know they do a lot of
smart things because like it's a our
hands are tied back so you have to like
investigate
you know a little bit different you know
outside the box sure sure sure you know
and when we did our mid-level which was
like our long-term anything that lasted
you know months could last a year and a
half you know that was we would
investigate we would know most of the
time who were bonded from you know kind
of like that and you know you're a
little bit better prepared now the most
dangerous i always tell everybody and i
was over street level and that's what
tony was into and he worked mid-level
dope and he's on long-range dope and
stuff now but the street level was
always the most dangerous because number
one it's kind of like being a vacuum
cleaner salesman that you know back in
the day you're going to go knock on the
door that you have no clue and try and
tell them something we're going to go
knock on the door we're going to stop
somebody on the street and try and buy a
dope from them
and you know you're going to get the
reaction of it's going to be somebody
that you know like can i cuss
they're going to say [ __ ] you
[ __ ] i don't do dope you know or
you're going to rob your ass because you
know i don't know this white boy calling
up in here you know and you're going to
give me you know and and i got a
remember the guy that was in the prison
was in prison for bank robbery and the
funniest store in the world
we were buying dope from this guy down
in uh close to allendale area and our
walkie-talkie fell out on the ground and
he picks it up and this guy's already
showing us all the bullet holes he's
been in angola for 30 years showing all
the stab wounds and uh
it was a funny i mean i couldn't help
start laughing and he goes up oh oh i
said oh [ __ ] man dropping radio goes
damn that looks just like a police radio
he picks up he said man that's heavy
just like a police radio and uh i was
dying laughing i'm like no no we were
construction this is my boy and the
other guy in the car was i said that's
my brother
by the end i'm just dying i'm laughing
so hard and he stole our money of course
you know but i mean that was just some
of the the funny [ __ ] that could have
turned deadly right then because we had
no idea and that's the street level dope
like i said [ __ ] we've been robbed and
shot everything but because you're just
you've got to have just the biggest nuts
in the world to pull up to somebody you
don't know and approach them or get out
and pull behind somewhere they're going
to direct you somewhere you know and we
would do
what was the most 30 something people a
day we've done before on those yeah i
think we've i think we've had yeah 40
50. yeah i mean we were just insane how
many people that would sell this dope
you know and then but i i think that's
the most dangerous because i have no
idea who i'm buying from then i don't
know if that guy just killed somebody i
don't know you know he wants my money
yeah it's what he's kind of describing
too is like so we're in street level so
it's short-term investigative narcotic
work so
normally we're narcotics but we kind of
were the the band-aid for the city if
there was a violent crimes and you know
a certain neighborhood they would send
us there uh sometimes in unmarked cars
trooping jumping outs things like that
but we also did short-term uc work and
that's what he's saying is we don't know
who we're dealing with because it's not
a long-term investigation we're just we
might see john walking down the street
we're just gonna roll up hey man you
know you got some green or you got some
you know whatever and and just go from
there obviously if john's not a dope
dealer he's not going to sell it to us
if you know
if he is you know what i mean he might
you know create a team bro yeah yeah
yeah yeah and uh
we don't do a whole lot of that
anymore here i mean i've talked about
with the guys in baltimore a ton but in
your opinion like why do you think the
sort of
you know plainclothes aggressive union
or taking the fight to the criminal type
uh uh policing why is that getting
abolished in this country i think the uc
work
now is mostly done and like he's still
doing it it's by informants and it's a
lot more safer you know for the law
enforcement guys and stuff like that
when i first started in the game back in
84
i mean you know you would go and just
buy dope i mean a lot of times you
didn't have some backup and stuff like
that we didn't you know you could wear a
wire sometimes the technology sucks so
bad i mean you know you may stick a
freaking gigantic tape recorder in your
pocket and nobody knows what's going on
and it's you know it's dangerous for the
agent but if you have an informant there
you know that are embedded with them you
can buy dope and they'll prosecute off
the informant stuff these days
but you were very much like on your own
i mean i know you were kind of like with
biker gangs for a long time you were
very much on your own sort of playing
playing parts basically yeah i mean i
was an actor but you know i mean i
didn't get like bad reviews i'd just get
killed if i [ __ ] up real bad you know
but to me you know i loved it i used to
do this thing all the time in fact you
know nowadays you can't do it the uc is
not allowed to unless it's an emergency
affect the arrest because number one
they think he pulls out a gun a badge
you're like oh this son of a [ __ ] is
jacking me you know
so it's real dangerous but back in the
day and i'd always say man i've been
buying dope for somebody and i'd say man
i got some good news and bad news you
know like oh [ __ ] what's the good news
and i said i got a job you're like no
[ __ ] and i pull out my bag he said
what's the bad news you're under arrest
[ __ ] yeah and it was fight or
flight you know and i loved it i mean
that's what i was hoping you know that
moment right there
and you know so many of them i had them
before like i pulled a badge like man
that's cool where'd you get that thing
at no no you're under arrest
[ __ ] no yeah all right man i
gotta go no no you don't understand
you're under arrest
and you know i mean i have all kinds of
funny stuff yeah it's like that's what i
wanted i wanted that [ __ ] you know and i
wanted to do it before the other guys
came in because i wanted him to catch me
in the middle of a brawl you know i mean
that was it you know that was the
funnest thing in the world and i had him
before i had a guy that used to buy a
meth from and he would give me a gun he
would say now look at the [ __ ] he
looked just i call him charlie mansion
and i actually have a picture of him and
show you he looks just like charles
manson and he would give me a gun when
he would go get my dope for me he said
now look the [ __ ] cops come to my
house you kill them i was like okay
i'm gonna shoot him when he go so he'd
always give me a pistol and he always
had another one here and the day that i
decided to bust him i brought my partner
in and he hid in the bedroom
and i did the good news bad news with
him you know but he was nuts and he just
started laughing like crazy and i'd put
in the gun that he gave me on the little
coffee table and unloaded it and so he
looked at me looked at that guy and i
was like [ __ ] of course he dove for the
unloading gun so i didn't shoot him but
he ended up whooping his ass pretty good
but he didn't even think about the gun
in his pants yeah he just saw that one
right there but he just laughed like
crazy but that's i live for that stuff
you know and that's towing today we've
worked undercover together many times
and i mean it's just a it's a it's an
adrenaline rush yeah and for me i'm not
a real
speaker i don't i kind of don't like
that interaction but it kind of gets me
out of that comfort zone doing it you
know making me speak to people i don't
know so that in itself is kind of a
little rush for me and then of course
learning from him just rolling up and
just
you know
just talking to people i learned so much
from from
just that you were old school you were
pounding the pavement
so like when this detective lieutenant
i'm sorry yeah lieutenant detective
right uh when he puts that case together
it's like i did this i saw that now with
informants you know you're dealing with
someone that
the information does come in
but it's like you have to triple
quadruple
you know you have to check that because
if you write a warrant based off what
the informant says and it's wrong that's
one of the detectives so what i'm saying
so like i like that version better but
like the powers to be don't like it
because
he's out there i feel like the people
that like him that did it should be
allowed to do it and like you you know
like you're more so on the surveillance
i would say right you use more more like
today's technology right and the
informants yeah yeah right yeah you see
what i'm saying like it's a beautiful
combination they both work
but
and i was privileged to get a little bit
with him and now because yeah so i was
able to get to uc work do all that learn
from him now we're kind of making two
months so so it's
oh yeah right because you learn from all
these techniques
you're working on the way you're working
so like when he leaves
right these these newer guys they don't
we don't get that
and that's what we're missing i gotta
say i work in baltimore but being down
here this is wow
but it's like it's cool but like it's
different it is different i can imagine
working these streets and you know and
i've of course met narcotic agents and
and cops from all over the freaking
world you know been to so many you know
different
uh
narcotic conferences and everything you
know and we all every nothing to cover
narcotics could have been too we all no
matter where they're from we were
brothers like that i mean you just knew
you know especially back in the 80s and
90s and stuff
i mean we all had that same you know uc
mentality and i've never met a freaking
undercover agent that was worth the [ __ ]
didn't have a gigantic ego and like to
every narc has an ego i love my boy here
he's got an ego i promise him does he
have an ego
oh yeah how many times he showed you his
abs
huh is that i see she knows oh yeah
i want to touch back on something too
it's kind of bothering me the whole
carrying
i i don't care when i did undercover
work and i went to a school
that that kind of taught me the dangers
the pros and cons of it and i took away
from it was how much money's gonna kill
you they're gonna i mean if you don't
understand you can do right and and with
us doing short-term stuff is we got some
of the baddest dudes on the apartment
that are i'm gonna block away you know i
mean so doing doing the short-term stuff
you got to you've got a react team
that's following you going everywhere i
got the baddest dudes in the city that's
going to be there if something happens
they're going to be the one to
to handle if you know so so i never
carried and and i did initially when i
first started doing it but once i went
to a school and just kind of i don't
understand tony so why why
so you're saying because if you have the
gun on you
i just felt dangerous yeah i felt like
it would my confidence i just felt
because i was always just worried man
can they see it can they see it
yeah and then you know yeah just yeah
but obviously because i mean i carry it
in the holster you know
dope fiends or dope dealers don't
usually carry it in the holster so i
mean it's a lot you know just it was
just self-con i knew it was there i was
worried they knew it was there and i
just feel like if i if i needed help man
they're right there and that's i mean
that's how we do it up yeah and but you
know but it's really just kind of
preference like i said he would carry i
think the other guy would carry a lot
and and now i carry where i go
you know outside of that but i just
uh
it's cool what you said that uh you
don't like having the gun
because
because of the confidence right so that
it forces you to think your way out of
this situation which is again one of the
coolest things you could ever do like to
think on your feet and it's like if i
[ __ ] up i could die so let me yeah and
you know i've done so much long-term
stuff i mean you know cases i've worked
eight and a half you know 18 months two
years and i mean i've been felt up you
know something and i've had them before
you know like they you know i had the
girls you know that's what their job was
to do dealing with certain groups they'd
come hug on you and they'd feel and
they'd like oh what's that you know i
said i ain't going there without that
and they'd pull their [ __ ] neither do we
you know i was like at least i know
there aren't
you know i always wanted and i did
election a ton of stuff by myself you
know i mean
that was my my high that was my
adrenaline rush and
my a lot of times back then there was no
backup i mean they couldn't hear you you
know if you did have a wire on it wasn't
the [ __ ] back then anyway you know so
that to me i always want to be able to
have a gun because i've been in
situations before i mean some crazy
situations
where you know i've had to rely on you
know knowing that i had a gun and stuff
like that and and just and also just to
go back on uh
you you think that the reason why
they're not putting undercovers out
there in that way anymore is for officer
safety you know it it's a lot of guys i
know that used in nothing but informants
we had uh street you know he he was he
didn't he was one of the best on
narcotic agents but he never were he
just didn't do undercover very well and
he used nothing but informants but it's
always safer because you know your
informant's already there he's already
embedded him with that group they know
him they've already bought selling dope
to him and usually an informant you know
you got the mercenary was doing it for
money you got the guys that they catch
you know and they're going to either you
know you're going to work or go to jail
and you know i told you before 99. nine
percent of them are going to afraid i
[ __ ] yeah i'll work you know i don't
want to spend a bunch of time in prison
so you know and then working off the
ones working off charges and stuff like
that so
it's a lot safer because they they're
already in there you know and i agree
sometimes that you know certain and
certain organizations are not going to
let a new person in there but i guess i
you know because i know like you know
the other thing that you know obviously
spending this much time in baltimore
especially baltimore police you know
it's basically a northeastern city so
you got just liberal it's just like a
different kind of like political agenda
and i guess like being here we're in
louisiana you know this is considered
like deep south part of the reason and
correct me if i'm wrong but
at least the way that i thought it is a
lot of the reasons why the flex squad
units got disbanded
wasn't just because of like the
corruption of wayne and all that
[ __ ] was because basically the
majority it's the same thing that my
friends in lapd tell me those groups
have been disbanded to jump out boys the
units like that they've been disbanded
because that's where the majority of the
sort of complaints were kind of coming
from
look if police work's not pretty it's
that age-old thing if you're going to be
engaging the most you're going to have
the most problems that's why you know
with that sort of agenda we get rid of
we disband these units but that's also a
lot of folks feel like that's that leads
to you know enormous spikes in in
violent crime and i guess
have you guys being you know deep south
red state have have you guys
felt that as well like a change in
policing
he get he's actually owned he can still
yeah yeah i mean it's changing uh
it's it's we're fortunate here where we
are
that we still have this like the street
level type team that that we were on
where they're out there you know
gloves off in the in the community uh
you know
still stopping everybody and
and and reducing crime uh
you know it's obvious if if
you know we went to a time where they
were
not out there as much and crime kind of
went up and then you send them out there
and our street level isn't but about
it's probably less than 10 people
including probably like two supervisors
and probably six to eight people
depending on on staffing and what was it
back in the day it was i think it was
two
two super no you had two supervisors and
about eight to ten it was
and they've always kind of
attempted to keep that unit staffed
because it's a unit that like i said
we're the band-aid for the city anytime
there was an issue anywhere they send us
whether it was a go stop car you know
trooping traffic stop stuff like that or
to go hey y'all go you know do some
under short-term undercover work in
these neighborhoods get search warrants
but because it shows i mean we could
show up to a neighborhood i'll give this
an example in the neighborhood here they
were having burglaries a
ton of burglaries and man they couldn't
stop them they sent one unit in there
and try to help reduce it it kept going
so they sent us in there we had 40
arrests
uh by just trooping was trooping just
doing traffic shops uh terry stop stuff
like that
and we did 40 arrests in a four-day work
work period in the neighborhood that
they had already sent some other units
in that they were having issues with
burglary we shut down in the
neighborhood walking through that like
why does that reduce the burglary our
street level cars are blue cars
uh people know what they are they know
that we're we're going to get out we're
going to talk to you if you're walking
down the street if we got any reason to
talk to you we're going to
and they know that so that they're not
going to be outside doing anything i
mean they don't take long
we can be in a neighborhood for five
minutes make a first traffic stop and
they'll be like hey we already know you
are here you know it's already been a
mass text out so just our presence alone
what would shut down neighborhoods and
uh and just because of the history of of
street level uh just uh you know they
call them the jump out boys here and
just the history from the 90s
all the way up you know i i definitely
want to talk about training because i
know you guys tr you know the way you've
dealt with training and how important
training is and with everything with
your your hands your weapons like
everything it's [ __ ] you know
you know that's like if i if i want one
thing to change
you know as far as me not being at all
an expert but for my platform it's like
training [ __ ] training training but
um i guess my question is um if you're
going into a situation in any situation
with another group of people and
violence goes down you're either the
kind of person who's gonna like help or
you're the kind of person who's gonna
split and i know that that just exists
with me and and and i'm just wondering
if you guys can sort of talk about that
a little bit like what's your what's
your take is on that i actually had a
lot more in common sometimes with the
informants and the bad guys that you're
arrested you know than i did with normal
people because i would be out to dinner
my phone ring you know it'd be an
informant talking about selling dope and
i'd be in there talking how much they
want for that bird and this you know and
people are looking at me you know and
like who is this piece of [ __ ] you know
here looking but i related to them you
know i could relate to the people we
arrested you know because we lived in
that you know you're out on the street
like he said all we're with each other
and we're out on the street all the time
you kind of get to know those people and
that's the kind of kind of life you seem
like you're living especially when
you're working undercover because you
start
the lines start kind of blur right in
there you know because i mean i have had
to pull myself out before because i'm
like man i'm getting to be
liking these people a lot more than i
like some of the other people i know and
i'm getting to have a lot of in common
with you i mean that's how you kind of
had your nickname right yeah people
didn't want to sell you drugs because
you were too scary-looking like you were
yeah yeah that's how i got the name
booger from the revenge of the nerds the
nasty little guy on the show you know
and i was working for the dea at the
time and went to buy some dope and these
people were like no man we're scared
we're dope any good we're going to come
back and kill us in the middle of the
night so we're not selling you and i was
like wait a minute i'm too nasty to buy
your dope and i mean they just left me
they told me they're going to call the
cops on me if i didn't leave their house
and i was just sitting there like the
crickets chirping i was like holy and i
met the guys that that i was working for
at the time you know they're all
clean-cut guys and you know like man you
may need to clean up you know i'm like
[ __ ] it's time to take a bath or
something you know but i do i related to
those kind of people you know that was
kind of my life was with those and i did
see a lot of parallels in between their
lives and my life you know except i was
a good guy and they were a bad guy and
you had to kind of remember that all the
time you know but when you live and play
the undercover role you're playing a bad
guy
you know especially when you're living
it i mean i'd spend hours with them days
you know all i mean a year with
and you know you kind of get that
mentality like oh [ __ ] you know i gotta
remember on the police here have you
ever been in situations with folks where
you you've seen guys on your unit where
you felt that they weren't willing to
kind of they weren't willing to kind of
jump into the fight or have you have you
ever seen it or are they just not making
on that yeah or vice versa you see guys
who take it too far well narcotic he can
tell you too we've had many people try
out and come and if they're if they're
not cut out for it they're not going to
freaking make it you know we've had cops
scared freaking i remember one guy that
uh he came to narcotics and uh he was
with another agent so we're going to buy
some dope and he pulled up to the street
corner and he wouldn't roll his money
down he goes yeah i roll you in there
he goes nope he goes you gotta ruin your
win it sounds like half the writers yeah
oh my god yeah
that was funny he was like row he went
down nope he goes well we can't buy a
doping
and he's like trying to roll the guy's
window down you know i mean it was
freaking hilarious you know and
he was gone you know and so like that i
mean you know you ain't gonna cut a unit
and what and what about the opposite
you've seen folks who've been too
heavy-handed at times or folks that
you've had to pull back i know the only
people that were heavy-handed were the
force on force you know i mean we're not
i'm not out here if i'm going to fight
somebody i can't fight someone like him
you know i'm not going to be just
wrestling around you know when it comes
to he starts throwing punches well i'm
going to start throwing punches you know
i'm going to escalate as much as i can
to be able to get because i'm fighting
for my life out there you know until
somebody my guys get there but i mean
you know we were always taking care of
business back in the day but now did we
like you know i mean some crazy
incidents where we beat the crap out of
somebody for no reason no you know and
the supervisor you know couldn't allow
that you know anyway
because especially in the days of you
know freaking cell phone technology
everything a cop did everything they do
is on camera you know i mean
everything's on video so i mean you
don't want to i don't want this guy
because he pisses me off to cost me my
life my livelihood
so you know and if any of my guys would
ever do that say okay hey that's enough
you know
well yeah a lot of times like if we see
somebody we think you know
that's went a little overboard you just
step in hey man i got it i got it you
know you just kind of you know step in
and
let them know how i got it because
sometimes i mean if they do they're not
even on purpose they're just in
condition black and and it doesn't
happen often but when it does you just
you just kind of step in hey i got them
i got them you know and you
let them know how i got it now and you
can kind of walk off and and let me let
me deal with as far as being
heavy-handed but as a new officer i was
taught failure to disengage is is is
99 of your complaints so meaning if i
put my hands on you once it's over with
i'm explaining to you why i did it hey
you know hey you know you did this i did
this you did you know and a lot most
times like all right i understand you
know
as long as you you explain what you did
i mean i've never had anybody have an
issue with it like oh i get it you know
i get it appreciate you explain it to me
so failure to disengage is you know
talking to people is real important
you don't get you don't get complaints
that way yeah
yeah it's it's yeah like i said most
times they know they did wrong but if
you explain to them why you did it or
you know hey well you did this i thought
you were doing you know i thought you
were going for a gun so you know i feel
you on the ground you know
they understand
what's going on right now man like
what's going on with all the violence
and the shooting and and what is from
your point of view now just my point of
view is
and really just everything going on in
the world as far as the pandemic uh low
you know low unemployment uh just all of
that to me is just a breeding grounds
for crime uh you know just that alone is
bringing grounds for crime uh you know
crime's going up in every large city in
america right now i mean i know
shreveport's not a large city
on the national side but it's the third
largest here in louisiana uh
we're we're two away from from our
record murder i think uh retirement what
is it for todd uh 87. yeah and we only
have about uh
i think we're around two hundred
thousand people
87 87 hummus and that's not true i mean
they're shootings everywhere so yeah so
i tell people like yeah so we were at
probably between 400 and 500 shootings
in shreveport now that's shooting where
somebody was hit with a bullet uh it's
about the number we're at so that's not
you know we have a phenomenal hospital
here and they and we got a phenomenal
fire department here i mean and they do
wonders when people get there so we're
thankful for them but
uh
it's uh
i mean 400 shootings 500 shootings
that's a lot yeah i was talking to you
know rich wilson you know and he told me
that 80 of the people he knows have been
shot yeah yeah oh man yeah and you know
it's always a wildest thing a cop to get
shot with a 22 caliber pistol but a guy
on the street can get shot nine times
you know with a 45 and he's not going to
die it's mentality my wife's one of my
wife's brothers uh so my wife she's from
cedar grove just a neighbor a low-income
black neighborhood and that's where
she's born and raised so she's got three
brothers
that are known gang members one's been
shot in the head and in the artery he's
still alive thank god but i mean you
know
it's uh do you get along with those guys
i do i mean i really i mean they really
they just chose different different and
i'm a believer that police and and some
criminals are kind of we're kind of
walking the same line i mean we're not
much different other than you know we're
not committing the crimes but
um
you know
we we keep but i mean there can be a
real mutual respect there right there
what's something you i mean besides
obviously you're brother-in-law's but
like what's something you've seen
from from a guy on the other side what's
something that you've seen that you
deeply respected
like as far as have you seen anything
from the quote unquote criminal element
in this city where you say you know
that's a stan you you know i respect
what that guy just did
oh
that's kind of hard question i mean
maybe maybe there's maybe maybe the
answer is you haven't seen it yeah i
mean yeah i mean you know you
a lot of the
a lot of the gang members have loyalty
to each other i mean that's obviously
something you can
kind of stand behind but i mean do you
feel like that loyalty is much different
than the loyalty that y'all have to each
other i think it's all the same uh you
know they
they got a brotherhood and they're gonna
stand with it so
you know you can respect that i mean
whether i agree with it or not you know
you can respect that that they're loyal
well i can tell you like when i got
ready to retire i had informants
i had crying i mean i had them coming to
me and saying man i cannot believe
you're going to leave you know what am i
going to do i'm like [ __ ] you better
stay out of trouble that's all i can
tell you and i would run into people
that i've already i mean i can't go
anywhere without i'm running somebody
i've arrested you know and always all
the time people will come up to me so
you remember me and i'm like that's
somebody i arrested you know
and i've had them so many times come up
and shake your hands and man you saved
my life you know how many that's
happened so many times and people you
know if you treat people
decent you know they're going to respect
you if you don't make it personal i'm
not going to make it perfect it's just a
business to me you know i'll arrest you
you go to jail [ __ ] you know that
happened you know don't make it personal
you make it personal that's something
different but i you know i would talk to
people all the time i've arrested you
know it doesn't bother me a bit i'd you
couldn't go anywhere in this town
without running something i still do all
the time and that and treating people
with respect because any of us can be on
the other end and you know there's
points in our life that something's
occurred that's happened that's
steered us in the direction we are so
you know
i mean they they definitely have their
code on it but you know like i said all
the time i mean the majority of the ones
i've ever arrested they won't mind
telling on each other you know like we
talked about before you know the
snitches you know get stitches and all
that was the first guy that's going to
rat on somebody you know because you
know i mean really i mean how many times
they'd come informants would wear those
shirts and i'd like holy [ __ ] really
you're going to bring this here and
you're one of my great informants you
know if you were looking at going to
prison for the rest of my life [ __ ] yeah
tony did it
yeah right now i saw him do it yeah it's
like you said like the loudest like
like you know if you let's say we do a
star tournament there's five dudes in
the room the one that's the loudest you
know it's probably the one that's gonna
when you get him probably he's gonna
tell you everything you know he's gonna
be the least loyal out of the group you
know and the guys that just sitting
there just not saying anything and
they're probably not gonna say anything
i mean there's self-preservation no
matter what you know everybody's going
to preserve you know them set their
family and stuff like that and you know
they're looking at going to prison 20
years and they're like oh [ __ ] no you
know this guy's out there bad he's got
me selling dope for him yeah i'll tell
you all about him you know and we've had
informants that everybody knew they were
informal and people would still
you know
do dope and stuff with him it was the
craziest thing we had one that comes to
mind i stopped him we were doing the
trooping thing and i stopped him he
passed by me up on a certain area of
town and he had his like music going
crazy you know and you know i mean you
could smell the weed coming out of his
car and i pulled him over you know and i
said man you know in our blue cars i
said the hell are you doing and i said
you ain't got any dope in there oh yeah
man i got a bunch of crack in there he
goes but you know i gotta i said what
how do you remember that i was like are
you out of your freaking so i called his
handler the guy i said you need to come
over and get this idiot you know because
you know he's gonna go to jail and uh of
course all he ended up doing was having
to work off those charges in but
everybody knew and he told me he said i
got duck man i can't roll around up here
without [ __ ] dope in the car and i
was like are you insane you're telling
me that's and it's yes right there you
see it town
like i understand how in certain
situations if you talk about wayne
jenkins you talk about like super duper
crooked ass like corrupt cops which
there there's bad apples in every
[ __ ] you know that that blue line can
kind of
be toxic and bad but [ __ ] man like
if you don't want people out there like
running into that place
you you know like keep us safe like what
are you talking about like if you can't
understand that that's like heroicism i
just think it's it's so important that
people like know that you know i think
people people need to know that that
that you know guys are laying it down on
the line for each other every day in in
in this in this country and also need to
know that you know look there is there
is like real [ __ ] evil out there i
mean bam bam i'm saying man it's like we
need police and that's a guy who's spent
the majority of his life you know most
of his life is super max you know what i
mean like people have really forgotten
like what we really do like our military
goes somewhere and they know their enemy
see what i'm saying like gangs their
loyalty or they go and take a bullet for
themselves but it's only in that world
like we will take a bullet and save
everyone including ourselves
like i don't care that you're a gang
member but like if you're shot i'm here
to help you like there's a little kid
i'm here to help you
the whole spectrum of
of of humanity plus we take care of
ourselves and the reason why we're so
close is because we know
yes i helped that gang member that i got
shot the other day but if i'm shot will
he help me it's a 50 50 chance
and and but on that i've had people
where i give this story to people is
when i was on patrol i got a foot chase
with a guy threw some alleys through a
fence i mean he finally just gave up
because he realized that he wasn't gonna
outrun me and it was a long pursuit he
just laid down and i just went by
handcuffed and walked him back and he
just kept saying man you didn't beat me
up i didn't he was so baffled i didn't
beat him up and i'm like man you gave up
you know what i mean and i've seen that
guy
on a handful of other times i work that
neighborhood i mean he always that man
he respected me just because i didn't
you know i didn't beat him up but it it
goes back that that you know yeah that's
classic yeah i mean it's you know
and they know that yeah yeah and and
also y'all are working i mean you're
working together you know it's like
you're almost like you said you're
working together bad guys defuse the
situation yeah i mean you're surrounded
with 20 30 people they're like you know
you'll have a guy no no y'all what the
hell you know man i know town y'all back
up
yeah imagine just told me a sword the
other day when he was in a fight with
someone and his gun popped out and a guy
who like ran that block went and stood
over the gun and just like waited for
him to do he's like nobody's touching
this i was in the middle of a fight and
my my magazine ejected and like people
were coming up to me like oh here's your
magazine well i'm arrested yeah
what do you feel like how do you guys
feel about kind of guns in general in
this country i remember the first night
i think
we went on not the first ride along we
went on but we i think it was the second
right along we went on when we were here
it was a long ass time ago but i
remember there was like two guys that
were like obviously gang members and
like you guys pulled them over
and you said they were a gang member and
they like and i maybe it's my own i'm
[ __ ] up and i've been hitting the head
a long time and smoke a ton of weed and
all that [ __ ] but like you guys got
those guys out of the car and both of
them like had guns right there and you
guys gave them their guns back
and and like that to me like from a guy
who like grew up in dc i like
could and you said to me i remember like
yeah they'll probably it's hard giving
that guy that gun back because like that
guy will probably shoot at a cop and
like like that baffled the [ __ ] out of
me man so can you guys just explain to
me like what the laws are and how you
feel about them
in state louisiana uh your car is an
extension of your home so you can have a
weapon concealed in your car here all
day long and everybody we know carries a
gun i mean it's just we're a gun
carrying state and you know
we always assume that they're packing i
mean you always do and if you as long as
you do that then you're never really
taken off you know balance or anything
like that but
everybody carries a gun here and i'm a
big second amendment guy you know like
if you've been to my house should i give
you guns you know i mean you know i said
here you better carry this anytime
you're going out in her purse right now
i guarantee it you know she does
and you know i mean
until they
nobody has guns and i think that
everybody should have the opportunity to
carry a gun yeah and i'm just i said i'm
a big gun guy i love them you know it's
a hobby with me you know i collect them
i mean i got world war ii weapons you
know i got all kinds of guns and stuff
like that
and uh but i always assumed the bad guy
was on no matter what as long as you did
that you were fine but as long as
they're not a convicted felon and
they're not carrying illegally concealed
they get the gun back can you explain
that illegally concealed yeah i mean in
state louisiana you can have a concealed
carry permit and we have actually parish
ones that you can go as long as you're
not a convicted felon or you're not
convicted of domestic violence then you
can get an a uh a concealed carry permit
to carry a weapon concealed on you so
that so the so those two guys in that
car they didn't have concealed carry
permits but during the car
it doesn't matter no it doesn't matter
that's an extension of your home you can
have that gun anywhere hidden in your
car or whatever and stay louisiana so
it's pretty easy to get guns here oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah as long as you're
not going to be yeah i mean as long as
you're not a convicted felon as long as
you don't have domestic as long as you
don't have any type of mental
uh like you never been in a mental
hospital anything like that you know if
you have it in your car you can have it
anywhere as soon as you step out of your
car
you can't have it now you can carry it
on your hip as long as it's just as long
as you can see it uh you can you know
throw a shotgun
and you can see like we have open
carries
right so so if you so if it's open you
don't need any apartment anybody in the
city can roll around with the guns as
long as everybody
yeah and what's the what's the
rationality behind that
well we've always been a sportsman's
paradise we've always been a southern
state that have always carried with no
but what's the rationality to being able
to see it like why do you need a permit
to conceal it and and you don't need a
permit to to
that's all it's always been the the
state louisiana law concealed
to be a concealed carry permit holder
it's kind of like it's almost a
privilege to be able to carry that gun
without anybody knowing that you have
that gun now i see people with open
carry and for me personally that's i
i don't think you should open carry as
long as you can get a concealed carry
permit you should if you're going to
carry carry it concealed because the
first guy that you go into a bank to rob
he's going after that guy with a gun and
that guy probably does not have the
training that we did to be able to you
know to be able to keep to do weapon
retention we were trained so much in
academy and and we went through all we
did all the time especially at srt
training swat training stuff you know
for conce you know to be able to retain
that weapon and to fight somebody for
that you know that gun but you got i
mean you guys have lost i mean you guys
have dealt with all you know
multiple officers that have been shot
out here gun violence is like kind of
like skyrocketing i mean if you
if
are you guys happy with the gun laws
down here i mean i know not for yourself
i know for yourself but i mean like do
you would you if you could change them
would you
or and what would how would you i don't
think you could change them without
saying okay you know well
he can't have a gun because i don't like
his tattoos you know as long as you're
not convicted felon you know and i have
no problem anybody being able to protect
themselves and honestly most most people
who commit crimes with with guns didn't
obtain them a lot legally anyway i mean
my biggest issue with a gun owner is you
need to have proper
you should have proper training you
should go seek it it's not mandatory but
you should go seek it and then proper
storage the issue is the issue is people
just leave guns in their car leave the
car unlocked and people steal them and
then that's how these these game makers
get it so
so that's that's the to me that's the
biggest issue is just but just playing
devil's advocate on that tony like isn't
it just that like if guns are this
readily available and it's so it's so
easy to get them that just makes more
guns and more available for the criminal
element to get them
and not and again i'm not made i totally
hear you like if there was a world in
which nobody had them that would be cool
you know like whatever but like now
everybody has them so you better believe
i'm gonna have one so and and i i get
that and i understand it i guess
i guess what i'm saying is like
they're gonna they're gonna get a weapon
somehow they're gonna have a gun yeah i
mean they're gonna they're
they're going to get guns somehow i'd
rather good citizens haven't gone off
yeah
we had a place called sport south which
is out south of town that uh it's a big
uh gun they get guns from all over the
kid we had a whole pallet stolen one
time of handguns stolen and i remember
for years we were still finding those
guns on the street you know but and also
to i think like he said about it's
i think it's a necessary evil you know
to have and i carry a gun not just for
protection of me my my family but you
walk into a situation and there's
somebody that's got a bad guy's got a
gun on somebody you know i can take care
of that situation you know i can save
somebody's life by doing it my biggest
issue is people just need to do proper
storage right they leave guns in their
cars and that's a big everything pisses
me off yeah and it's running cars
and that's how that's how a lot of times
a lot of times how they
they obtain these illegal guns just
because they like door checkers they
just walk through neighborhoods in the
middle of the night and they'll have a
car usually driving down the street or
parking one side and there'll be two
guys and they get out and they walk
through neighborhoods and they check the
doors you'd be surprised you'd be
surprised
i mean you can probably go into an
apartment complex
and i bet you you probably find 20
unlocked car doors
just on any given night that's wild
so does the guns have to be in plain
sight or do they have to be concealed
no
your house in state louisiana your car
is the extension of your home you can
have that thing hidden in the glove
compartment but but can it be in plain
sight also oh yes again
no that's so crazy
is the first thing you guys ask on the
car stop is do you have a gun in here oh
yeah i mean that's you always you know
you got any weapons or anything you got
any bazookas you got your hand grenades
inside the car and most times yeah i
gotta go yeah okay man where's it at i'm
gonna clear we're gonna we'll check
clear the gun make sure it's not stolen
make sure you're not convicted felon i'm
gonna put your gun you know i'm gonna
set it in the trunk right now you drive
down the block you can get your gun out
load it you know right yeah remember
yeah yeah don't get don't pull over and
get it right now you know you wait you
know just so they can't readily get it
and just decide to you know open up real
quick i just want to just go back to
that training thing um and and just like
the amount of i mean you you were
telling me the other day about how you
know you guys used to go into houses and
stuff like that and once you cleared the
house and they were out you would go
actually then train and practice in that
house yeah we would utilize anything for
a training situation if we could like
we'd do search warrants until we get the
situation cleared out i mean we would go
okay let's do a run back through you
know especially if there was something
that you know kind of we hesitate there
was a weird situation in the house that
was a a fatal funnel we went in that you
know we hadn't seen before a layout of a
house and we would use that as a
training opportunity okay you know get
the bad guys out we go especially if you
have a new guy you have a new guy you
can walk through the house of why you
did what
you know uh
for like srt related stuff most of the
time well now they have stuff where you
can you know they have bridging doors
and stuff like that but for the longest
you were just on the job training
preaching talking about you know with
the ram stuff like that so
a lot of times you can kind of go back
through and and kind of get a little bit
of on job training that way with them
and you guys on your own in your unit
we're just kind of constantly trying i
mean there's martial arts there's
weapons you know
i mean we've been talking all this about
guns but like how important would you
say the the physical hand to hand uh
stuff who was it that i was training
with in your garage oh stephen joe man
yeah oh yeah yeah
oh yeah i may have fourteen guns he's
got about twenty three on that one he's
shorter and then he had me do the knife
fight yeah yeah he's like literally he's
like no then you just do that i'm like
well now my wrist is broke and he's like
do it again i was like now my other
wrist is broke i'm like god damn dude oh
yeah [ __ ] actor bro he goes
he'll train he'll go he goes down in
latin america he's trained crazy he is
he is insane was everyone on the union
unit trained uh with with with uh
physical hand-to-hand comments yeah i
mean we
knife train we had everything knife
defense we had i mean every kind of
trainer and we took opportunities all
the time like even if we had a slow time
we were working
i'd let him go to the range you know
whatever you know the more you train the
more perfect and it's it's almost i
teach guitar like i was telling you for
the guitar for vet saying and teaching
guitar is no different than teaching
firearm training it's all muscle memory
it's my opinion that the ones that can
handle themselves are the ones that can
go look people in the eye be cool in
this situation would you say that's
right yeah i i definitely gives you
confidence and then there's another
thing we call we always call verbal judo
that you know you should be able to
you can talk yourself you know into
situations you can talk yourself out of
situation and we all know cops said as
soon as they arrived on the scene it was
just something about them you know i can
be talking to a guy we're sitting there
talking he's calm this other guy pulls
up i mean that guy goes completely off
on i mean you know you [ __ ]
because he could not defeat he would
just incite it more just for presents
but you've seen the same [ __ ]
being able to treat people well also
comes with having a sense of confidence
on yourself right yeah
yeah yeah i think yeah if you're if
you're confident in yourself yeah you
don't have to go be the loudest one in
the room because you you speak for
yourself by just the way you carry
yourself so
yeah and i think that's
accurate and being trained up that
builds confidence in yours and people
can tell confidence they can tell
they would know you pull up on the scene
they would know the shaky guy that's not
real you know he doesn't he's not the
guy that goes to the range on his own
he's not the guy that works out he's not
that that guy and they could tell that
and you know they could take advantage
of the weakness and stuff people
especially guys that on the street they
can read
us
they know how do you describe kind of
the bottoms and and those guys and the
bottom boys and some of these these
folks that you know obviously you know
this this story in that community that
came into my life because of the story
you told me you know we've been kind of
doing this together for a long time and
in that process i've gotten to know
these guys and gotten close with some of
them and um who are those guys to you
you know it was a job it was a job but
you know and i told you a story about my
mom that happened and we never found out
who was involved in that i know it was
you know it was part of that
investigation that i did and that's the
first time that's you know i've had
people jump on me stuff like that you
know hell i've had more money out on my
head i was like commit suicide i could
make more money killing myself then you
know you know you had people always
wanted you dead and stuff like that but
uh you know that was the thing that got
me was you know what happened to my mom
she was beat up over that situation
during it and we never found out who did
it you know never found out who called
it who ordered it if it was somebody and
i'm sure it was a youngster maybe
involved in it because that's the ones
that that's the most dangerous that you
ever see the guys the young ones that
are trying to make a name for themselves
same thing in the motorcycle community
you know the ones that are the prospects
and stuff like that they were just a job
to me you know it was an assignment and
i liked it because we made a difference
you know for the people that lived there
they were pretty much the people that
were down there were held captive you
know by the the situation they were
involved in and once we cleaned i mean
it you drive through there now it's not
near the same i mean they it's totally
different down there
you know i mean the crime that was
police cars wouldn't go down there
unless there were several together
because of all the
violence
and and it just was specifically like
those guys like you have i mean you
haven't seen
goat you haven't seen alfred brown and
not that you're right no not those yeah
you know some of the ones that went i
think there was 48 arrested and the uh
12 11 went federal and they got the big
got the big time now the other ones yeah
i've seen them all you know so like for
those guys like i guess it's like go
you know big don
bam bam
like those guys like who who are those
guys like back then who were they sure
oh they were the ogs there was the guys
that ran the you know the original gang
members they ran
that whole area everybody knew
everybody knew who they were and that's
why we knew that once we got took the
big guys off that that whole area would
crumble down there and it did but you
know like i said it was an assignment to
me you know just like any as long as
they don't take it personal i don't take
it personally
that was a big deal yeah so i mean i was
i was born 86 so all that was i was
i mean
way before me but yeah i had a big year
no i'm trying to do the math i'm like
[ __ ] yeah i graduated i started in 84
yeah the uh
but it had a big impact on the community
of shreveport because that was you know
from understanding it was a large gang
they were terrorizing you know the the
city and uh
and crime's been down since then and now
we're kind of now we're starting to see
that again did you hear anything about
those names specifically like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're yeah they're i
mean they're legends everybody knows
that mainly just the story of the
bottoms in general police cars wouldn't
go down and they'd flip police cars over
uh they wouldn't go down there by
themselves they would wait for no get
you know a large number before they'd go
down there and sometimes i didn't
respond to things so
you know sebastian richardson he's out
now you know like oh i mean they're
pretty much all out now you know and and
and it seems like the main focus
of what these guys want to do now is you
know look goats lost two of his
daughters to gun violence since he's
been out you know um
you know the wilson's reginald wilson
and richard wilson their sons kind of
you know they they're extraordinarily
worried about him you know like quick
you know he's he hit his son you know
he's he's he's in for murder right now
you know i mean they just see this kind
of like eating up their own kids and i
think whether it's i'm not gonna
try to
psychologize you know why they that you
know why they feel this way but i
seems to me that what's first and
foremost on all their mind is trying to
make a difference now and trying to say
that you know since they've been through
what they've been through that they
could do
do you think that they can be helpful
yeah i mean yeah i think i think they
can uh
you just you know the new generation of
of gang members or just
new generation in general is just
different from what it was that's what
they said and
you know what makes them different tony
they don't really live by code then they
had a code but i mean so just an example
like if let's say me and you arrival
gang members and i see you i'ma shoot at
you on site you know whether your wife's
with you you're famous with you doesn't
matter and whoever's in the way is going
to get shot well when they would live
nicely when they'd live by code that
they would they would get you and not
you know not anybody else and and me and
carl might be in a gang today and then
we might you know be beefing or arguing
and then he might come join your gang so
they switched they i mean you really try
to keep up with who's who
but i mean
there are some larger gangs that have
been
uh that are well known here now in
shreveport that are that are really
taking over like would you ever feel
like would you be willing to and i'm not
asking i'm like like just
philosophically would you be willing to
like work with those guys to try to make
it oh yeah 100 i think sign up as a
police officer you're trying to make a
difference in your community it's not
just by arresting people but talking to
people yeah 100 it's funny that you say
that because i'm actually kind of going
through that with you know i told my
wife's brothers but
uh we recently had a nephew uh that was
that was murdered in a gang oriented
deal this year but his brother's kind of
going that same little that same road so
we're trying to kind of mentor him and
there's not so much i can do because
i'm you know i mean he don't want to
hear that from me and uh
but so it's kind of going through that
same little deal he's trying to you know
he's young he's not even 18 yet his
brother died
it wasn't on his 18th birthday but he
had just turned 18 and uh
and then he's like 16. he's on that same
road you know just trying to but they're
different you know when when when we
work together like you know uh
a big influential gang like that teams
up with police like when pena king and i
walk through the streets and they may
not know me but now they're like oh okay
it makes my job easier
it makes
do you guys agree oh yeah oh yeah and
it's like yeah we're down because it's
like we get one common cause piece yeah
what what you'd be surprised how many
how much you have in common with people
and i use my i'm from the country she's
from cedar grove
i mean we lived
if i told you our two lives you'd like
they would never meet i'm white she's
black she's from cedar grove i'm from
the country everything about us is
different but we have so much in common
i think everybody has so much in common
that that if they can sit down and talk
like part of the problems with some of
the protests and stuff is everybody
wants the same thing honestly everybody
wants the same thing most people who
watch some of the stuff that's been
going on
most of your good police didn't agree
with it you know but but most time we
don't we can't have an opinion i can't
get on facebook and and say what i want
to say i can't because
on either side you know i mean i can't
defend them which i wouldn't defend most
of them but i also can't go in and say
certain things because there's obviously
policies and procedures we got to follow
but then that we all want the same thing
and if
if we could all get in the same room and
talk i think people would realize
of how much we do have in common that's
awesome man yeah i think that that's the
whole kind of idea of you know what i'm
what i'm trying to do now and and a big
thing i'll be honest with you man like a
big reason why also i mean besides sort
of like what i was saying before i want
to do this podcast and [ __ ] but you know
i've been coming down here 10 years oh
yeah i almost feel like i got divorced
parents you know what i mean because i
want to see him i want to see go you
know what i'm saying and it's like and i
know that and i'm like looking i'm like
both y'all would [ __ ] like each other
you know what i mean and it's like the
one thing i just do know is that we all
just want our kids to be safe we all
just want the world to be we want some
peace of mind out here and and enjoy
ourselves and just like i said earlier
it's really just man we all could have
been
on the other side yeah i was raised by
my grandmother
my mom worked all the time my dad left
where i was born i grew up in
queensborough which is you know i mean
that's a hell of a neighborhood you know
and i mean
if i had to change certain things i
would probably be on the other side
because i remember
calling going to juvenile court you know
for being in trouble and i had my
buddy's older sister come in pretend
like she was my mom because i didn't
want anybody to know you know come for
the judge you know she came in like she
was my mom you know
and uh yeah yeah he won't do that again
i was like appreciate you coming for me
i didn't want everybody know i was here
yeah and i had an uncle that was in law
enforce he was an undercover guy and uh
i always loved
adrenaline but i didn't want to go to
jail after i've been juvenile a few
times you know and i'm like you know
what i said [ __ ] i think i'm become an
undercover cop because i can live both
worlds that way and have all the
excitement you know
so
that's exactly what i used to tell
myself
i was like i don't want to be inside i
want to go outside i want to drive i
want to talk to people yeah i want to
yeah
hey uh [ __ ] man i i i really appreciate
y'all's time and and uh i'm i'm a better
man for having you in my life man so
thank you thank you peace
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff it'd mean a lot to us
i hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself